6 25 on your wednesday morning what's
cool it's cool how about a local junior
high school celebrating a big birthday
with an old-fashioned county fair
[Applause]
hundreds of students and their families
converged on the campus of the ko
knutson academy of the arts
not just to sing happy birthday for the
school's 60th jubilee
there were performances all around
including
[Music]
mariachi
[Music]
dance
band
and orchestra
[Music]
the cafeteria became the concession
stand where freshly made cotton candy
was a big hit so was the photo booth
with ko's tv production teacher heather
rampton it's great hanging out with
magnet coordinator shantae johnson and
the choir director amy sims and art
teacher shawn jones
speaking of art part of the gym was a
showcase for student art
and so was one of the sidewalks
very cool with the hashtag ko is 60
thanks to the principals leslie kepp for
inviting me and a shout out to the
thousands of successful las vegas who
spent some of their precious teen years
down through the decades at the now 60
year old ko knutson academy of the arts
you know something that's cool at school
let us know cool at school under the
community tab at 8newsnow.com or just
send us an email cool at school
eightnewsnow.com